c'est pas nos vaches si nos filles on
les appelle toujours nos filles donc je
me battrai jusqu'au bout là j'ai des
soutiens pas mal sur internet où les
gens sont prêts à venir se bat avec moi
pour imiter clip met pas à l'abattoir
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
mais
s'il n'y a pas de repreneur on n'en met
on emmène les bêtes au marché au cadran
elles vont ils ont dû des clopinettes
pour faire du steak haché et ça il en
est hors de question d'abord moi je suis
pas agriculteur je suis paysan c'est à
dire que je travaille avec la nature
c'est une passion c'est un mode de vie
les vaches passe toujours avant nous
[Musique]
mais
et
[Musique]
m
totalement révolutionnaire après avoir
fait 15 morts donc il faut faire
intervenir le vétérinaire pour les
nettoyer et ça ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent sur les quinze on en a eu six
qu'on est obligé de vendre parce qu'elle
était stérile
[Musique]
me faudrait peu pour vivre d'abord rien
le jardin il ya des blagues et puis d'un
on fait avec
et puis si j'ai quand même dépensé
toutes les économies de mes parents mon
père à 95 ans ma mère à 86 ans moi et
mon associé on est complètement
abandonné depuis 1 2 deux ans tout le
monde nous abandonne nous tourner la
tête
parce que quand on est en faillite on
est des pestiférés
je suis toujours prêt à faire n'importe
quoi
s'ils viennent chercher mes vaches je
ferais tout ce qui remet au pouvoir pour
sauver les bras